well let me bring in Phil Mickelson let
me start with that question Phil do you
think Phillip Rivers will be a Hall of
Famer that's a good question I don't I
don't know the answer to that I think
the NFL today and his that I think the
Chargers are getting better and better
and there's a very possible chance that
he went to Super Bowl long if he does I
think there'd be a for sure
hall-of-famer
who's your favorite team the Chargers
feel like a Chargers hand always will be
your favorite chart were you Dan Fouts
pen oh yeah air Corey Allen Lionel James
and Kellen Winslow and John Jefferson
and it was it was awesome to watch yeah
do you like going to the games or would
you rather watch at home with my kids
because it's a experience to share with
them but otherwise it's much more
relaxing just watching it at home you
can watch multiple games we were
wondering this have you ever had a job
outside of golf yeah I had a job when I
was eight years old
oh you mean outside off well I I guess I
guess that's area outside of golf I got
a job at 8 years old at the golf course
to be able to go play in practice ok and
get that all the way through high school
so I guess you know picking the range
and picking up trash in the pins out of
the holes late at night things like that
but it was all really just to be able to
play ball oh so you never worked it like
a Wendy's or a Denny's or anything like
that no no is caddying the best way to
get into golf if you were telling
younger kids no I think that there's
it's a good way I think it's a great way
but I think the best way to get the game
is to go down to your local municipal
course there's clinics there's
opportunities for juniors to play and
that's the best way to get started
that's how that that's how I think I
would get my kids started right Adam
lessons and death event clinics and
stuff early on phil mickelson joining us
coming off the win in mexico tigers
said he was inspired by your win on
Sunday did you see that well I think
that we've gotten pretty close over the
last couple of years with the team
events and his his great leadership that
he's had as a vice captain to write a
couple Presidents Cup and we've had a
really good relationship to last year's
and and we can pull it hard for each
other
because we both know and believe that we
have the ability to play compete against
these great players and we know how
great the players are today there we
also know and believe that we complain
compete against them and so seeing
somebody do it I said I think you know
he's always won up to me in my career
and I would be surprised if he came out
this week in one just to one-up me again
but how fronts frustrating they are a
Hall of Fame golfer but and you're a
competitor but when somebody one up for
you like how does that feel well it's
yeah first of all that sucks but let me
say this I have an appreciation for the
fact that I played and competed against
Tiger for all these years and in fact I
believe I would not have played as well
as I have throughout my career had it
not been for him nor would I have
elongated my career to this point and
have my body be healthy and so forth had
it not been for him he's the one that
got me started working out back in 2003
and granted a lot of a lot of my fitness
is hidden under those of fat but I've
worked hard to to strengthen all the
muscles that support my spine my knees
my shoulders to help elongate my career
and Shawn conquer my trainers been very
good at that effect on top of a gymnast
isn't it awful phone and so doing these
things has allowed me to elongate my
career
alright let's go around the room how
much we think Phil Mickelson can bench
all right
over under 225 Seton who's going over
Paul he's going on everybody but Seton
so can Phil Mickelson this is his max
all-time bench press Rory
so here
thing here's the thing again you're
talking about a bench press which I
would never do because your your entire
spine and back is relaxed while you're
creating a movement what I would do is a
bunch of TRX push-ups where you have
your hands in an unstable platform
I would elevate my feet on a physio ball
and if you want to see how many pushups
I could do on that that would be a
better judgment because when I do it
when I do a bench press a and I'm
working my chest muscles what I really
want to work are my shoulder muscles a
rotator cuff muscles that support the my
shoulders as well as my spine so I want
to activate my core for for golf you
would never want to be fully relaxed and
just work your big muscle that that
makes no sense that's how you get hurt
Rory is he said he'd he can do 260 and
he's a piece of bench press guy thank
but okay hypothetically what do you
think you get a lot of injuries - and
he's 25 or whatever oh I know I know
and Brandel Chamblee called him out for
getting too muscle-bound there so
hypothetically what do you say here call
me out for that hypothetically bench
press how much I would guess but again
I've never done it I only do push-ups on
the TRX and I'll and I'll make it harder
by elevating my feet getting me
underneath the TRX feet up against the
wall things like that so that it's a lot
more pressure but I would never do a
bench press you know we were also
wondering about this when you know the
approach like when does Augustus start
to come into how you play or when you
prepare for that as you're playing in
these other tournaments enters your mind
after the PGA Championship so you're
thinking about it for seven months or so
but January 1 is where you start to kind
of map out a game plan on how to get
ready for Gustav because you want to hit
the ball as long as you can that week so
you start mapping out workout programs
you start mapping out practice sessions
that are developed to increase speed and
then as we near now now we are we're
about a month away and used we start
having either these certain
workout programs all the way up to the
Masters and practice sessions to do work
on certain parts of your game and so
forth so right now I'm working on I've
got a practice session later today to
work on live cutting speed and so forth
and all in preparation for Augusta have
you ever had one of those Justin Thomas
moments where you had somebody ejected
it saw a heckler oh I'm sure I'm sure we
have but I haven't had that I've had you
know bones has been great about that in
the past our security guards and so
forth but you know you don't want one
one or two people who kind of cross the
line and and make everybody look bad and
so it's just easier to have people be
kicked out I don't know specifically the
moments that that has happened but I'm
sure it has
I also saw where Jimmy Walker PGA Tour
player was talking about he he slammed
the USGA about possibly reducing these
you know the distance these golf balls
go did you see that story with the USGA
and the RNA where there's studies
looking at you know do we reduce how far
you can hit it do you think well I think
I don't want to lose these great golf
courses i I still want them to play like
they should play
I understand modern technology but but I
do think it's gotten a little out of
hand I think it's a little crazy the
distance that guys are hitting the ball
I don't know you know I don't know how
to agree or disagree in the sense that I
I agree with what you're saying I also
don't feel as though the guys who have
been worth getting in the gym working
out like Dustin Johnson's and the
McIlroy guys that have been getting
after it should be punished because they
are increasing their distance we've all
known that the US did kept the overall
distance and drivers and Falls and so
forth years ago so you can really mostly
attribute it to the athletes getting
better and I don't feel that's right to
punish them either so I'm kind of caught
in the middle
but if I reduce the distance it can go
the guys who still hit it longer are
still going to hit it longer than the
other guys you're you're you're still
gonna have that separation you're just
not going to be driving par fours that's
that's the point that I wanted to make
if you reduce it 10% and the guy that
hits it 280 yards he's going to lose 28
yards of guys who hits it through 30
he's going to lose 333 yards so you're
going to punish him for what but you
played courses where and I don't know if
the scores are reflective of that but
you know back in when you were 27 and
playing of course at 47 you know that
it's a different course now for some of
these guys and I don't know if that
makes the game better or not maybe
that's what the bottom line is yeah I
don't think the answer to that I don't
really have a strong opinion because I
kind of have feelings both ways on it we
wanted to know if the shirts by the way
are tapered just to show the guns as
well like this does callaway make those
shirts just to taper to show off your
arms and the answer is yeah okay but
they're meant to accentuate their it
sends a message to the rest of the field
right is that what you're saying no they
were just kind of tailored but I really
appreciate this probably one question I
appreciate the most
thank you maybe we sponsor one of your
biceps here maybe we can get the show
and we get one of your your right sleeve
instead of your left sleeve there hey
congrats on the win that was awesome
LeBron said he's better now than he was
when he was 25 he's playing in an
all-time high you're 47 I believe how
are you better than 27
in areas for sure there's there's a
number of areas of my game and as I look
back 10 15 years ago I feel like I'm
significantly better me my overall
course management the way I do of course
I played much more consumable uh for my
current shot and the ability to be more
aggressive for my next shot when I was
always aggressive aggressive aggressive
in the past I feel like that's reduced a
lot of my mistakes and certainly I've
gotten a ton better at putting I'm not
one of the equal one or two and just
about every puttting stat this year and
and has significantly gone up the last
couple years through years of trial and
error and so forth and I'm actually
becoming a very average driver which is
a huge step up for me so I used to be I
used to give away a lot of shots on the
stat Stokes strokes gained driving and
now I'm not giving any away I'm just
about dead even and so that that is a
huge step up also but it's a lot more
work for me to be able to to do this
it's a lot more work before the round
it's a lot more work after the round I'm
not able to go to say dinners after the
round I have to take you know three four
hours to recover because I want to be
fresh and ready the next day my work
schedule is different for me to be able
to hit as many balls as I have to hit
I've got a half but a lot more time in
the gym and I thought I'd have a lot
more time recovering at night so it's a
lot more effort but I love this
challenge of being able to play and
compete against these guys and I'm
willing to and enjoying putting in that
effort if you work adding for a 25 year
old 27 year old Phil Mickelson what
would you tell him tell him that's a
good question I don't know I don't know
I probably just stay out of the way good
bones stay out of the way he was he was
awesome I mean we had we had a lot of
success together and we had a very
dynamic tennis
together you will as we spent 25 years
together so we both kind of evolved we
both were were different we were
different starting out then we moved up
and we both kind of grew and evolved
together final question if you didn't
become a golfer what was Plan B I would
enjoy a number of things I love to argue
so I think lawyer I'd be a decent
litigator I oftentimes will take the
opposite science and what I feel or
believe just simply to have a good
debate I just enjoy that and I think
that'd be a that'd be a field that I
would be that I would enjoy mitigation I
love that you're so competitive that
you'll take the other side just to see
if you could win the other side I think
that's important though in any debate is
also understanding the other side sure
what do you agree with it or not you
need to know both sides before you can
really have a well enjoy the week off if
that includes a week off with all the
practice but congratulations and by the
way I love the commercial with with your
daughter
voicing the big commercial I appreciate
it it's been it's been fun it's been fun
so thank you thanks for having me on
- it's appreciate over the many years of
my career all your support you've been
wonderful and I appreciate it my rogue
driver doesn't go as far as yours does
just want to let you know no but if he
swung it a little bit faster it was oh
well okay I'll try that
thank you feel good to talk to you
alright that's Phil Mickelson just won
in Mexico there at age 47 for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you